hey what is up guys I'm kid Bhd here and
welcome to the HTC one m9 hands-on so
this is the successor to one of the most
well-liked phones from last year the HTC
One m8 and most of the outside hardware
as you can see has stayed pretty much
the same
while the specs got the bump on the
inside so that's really the long story
short with this phone it's kind of like
the equivalent of the HTC One m8 s so
it's an incremental improvement but I
think in the best possible way because
the One m8 was already one of the best
phones of last year so of course it's
metal everywhere again and the minor
changes you get are you know one
additional color choice in pink and
there's also now a two-tone look so the
sides have a different color than the
front and back so this silver version
for example has gold stripes on the
sides where the buttons are and these
buttons are actually in a new place so I
mentioned in my what to expect video the
ridged power button has moved to the
right side underneath the volume buttons
so it's much easier to reach now here
and overall the metal has more of a
brushed look so you can tell that when
you put it up next to the One m8 now I'm
not sure how slippery is going to be
this one is on a tether so it's keeping
me from dropping it at all but I'm
feeling like it's gonna have the same
pretty slippery feel on the hand as the
One m8 so I think I'm gonna end up
putting a skin on it when I get it but
I'll at least give it a shot with no
skin or case for my full review but
otherwise on the outside the boom sound
speakers are still there so one year
later there's still some of the loudest
and crispest and clearest of any phone
and they're supposedly enhanced this
time around with Dolby surround sound
but I'll have to get in a quiet area and
test that out again for the full review
to see if it's worth the change but
otherwise yet still boom sound you also
still get microSD card expandable
storage so I guess that's something that
was noticeably missing from Samsung's
new flagship you also still get a 5-inch
1080p display so not quite HD and I
don't mind this really I suspect we'll
see quad HD in the next HTC flagship but
with a 1080p screen here we're still
getting 441 PPI and it's still a great
display you know awesome brightness
great colors great viewing angles in
fact this was one of the best 1080p
displays of any smartphone last year -
and I know some people wanted them to
get rid of that bottom but
with the HTC logo but you got to realize
the display drivers have to go somewhere
and that's pretty much all the bezel of
this phone you got to remember how much
space those speakers take up so the one
main hardware change that they really
made to this phone was the camera on the
back so that one m9 is rocking an
all-new 20 megapixel sensor no optical
image stabilization but it can take 4k
video now and of course now it takes
these very high resolution photos and
this is the number one thing I will be
testing in the full review process I got
to spend a little bit of time with this
phone obviously in a press room with
this crazy terrible lighting and it's on
a tether so I could really only point
and shoot at so many things and images
looked okay on the one screen but I
really want to go out and test this new
camera as deeply as I can bring images
back to the computer pixel peep and
everything so you can be sure that I
know the most that I can about this new
camera but you know we'll see how that
goes so obviously no more ultra pixels
on the back but they did stick around
and keep the ultra pixels for the
front-facing camera which is this really
wide angle lens and I guess that makes
sense for selfies so the ultra pixels
aren't gone forever but that new camera
module is definitely something to test a
lot now inside this phone like I said
you get a spec upgrade so Snapdragon 810
chip 3 gigabytes of RAM and HTC Sense 7
on top of Android 5.0 lollipop in the
software Department not a whole lot of
preloaded apps here and this new version
of sense does seem you know flatter and
smoother and more responsive as it
should on lollipop they've added some
new features like quick themes in the
settings and even this custom widget
which is essentially a grid of icons
that changes what apps show up based on
your locations so I guess it's supposed
to be smart enough that when you leave
home and go to work it switches over to
showing you your work apps so stuff like
that should work automatically and of
course you can manually toggle it if
it's not smart enough but also it will
apparently suggest some new apps that
you don't have installed so I hope that
works well and isn't distracting but
yeah you can see everything else looks
really familiar here to previous HTC One
owners multitasking is smooth all the
buttons and things you would expect are
right where you'd find them on the last
version I really can't wait to spend
more time with this phone off a tether
and in my pocket to really get to know
it well but my sentiment really I've
read a lot of these tweets and
people who are talking about oh I'm
disappointed with this phone or I really
expected more but if you're HTC you
really you took the one of the best
phones of last year in the one m8 and
you fixed and improved everything that
was wrong with it and you bumped up the
specs boom there's your one m9 I can see
why people are complaining because they
wanted a big design refresh and a huge
change but HTC can't do that every year
so if it ain't broke don't fix it I
imagine HTC is pretty happy with this
phone and all the changes they've made
seem to be for the better so the testing
will begin as soon as I get my hands on
one and I'm pretty pumped so be sure to
subscribe if you haven't already to be
one of the first to see the full review
when it does come out until then thank
you for watching this one and I'll talk
to you guys in the next one peace